dh limbisch, dass ich beide Licht mache
sie berauben ihr Minimum an Tee
Formular drucken, aber Putin schaut zu
ja, und von kompassstationen kiev scaffold
Informationen und wir wurden geboren und der Fluss lebt darin
stadt nikolaev in der ukraine
aber das war vor dem Krieg und
zweiunddreißig geboren
Du bist gegangen, als die Zeit begann
Und
waren wir zum essen figurinen von akuten schmerzen willen
Art von Auto-Obst, das ist mehr verdammt
klingender Schrei
plötzlich beginnt der Krieg von neuem
Ich hatte große Angst, weil ich schon
Ich habe es geschafft, all dies zu übertragen, und ich denke das
Alles wird wieder von vorne beginnen, was es mir gut tut
was habe ich in meinem Leben getan und nicht nur
Ich möchte, dass das wieder passiert, weil sie dabei sind
Produkte werden auch in Kiew verschwinden
sehr schnell
Haben Sie jemals erwartet, dass Russland es tun könnte?
gut angreifen, nie wirklich
Russischlehrer u
Literatur, die man sich vorstellen kann
Ich könnte mir überlegen, ob ich mich anmelde
Institut
Ich kannte Russland so, natürlich würde ich das nicht
war ein Lehrer der russischen Sprache und
Literatur
was denkst du darüber, was Putin entschieden hat
Es ist sehr schwierig, die Ukraine zu kennen
darüber zu urteilen ist nicht normal
ehrlich gesagt, urteilst du gut, wie aus der sache
die Augen eines gewöhnlichen Menschen, so dass
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass er gut ist
gleichzeitig weil
die Ukraine praktisch auf ihn angreifen
kein Grund
er sagt, es ist die gleiche Entnazifizierung i
Die Ukraine versteht nur, dass Sie verstehen
dass die Ukraine voller Faschismus ist
das stimmt aber nicht
hier lebe ich seit wie vielen Jahren für ein Fest in der Ukraine
und irgendwie
ging mich irgendwie nichts an, das ist alles
ist mir in Kindheitsgedanken passiert
Birke Mai Nationalität schrie nicht
danach war es die Region Astrachan
schreiendes Licht wer und
Ich wurde von der Schulleitung gemobbt
zeichnete gern ein Zombie-Logo auf das Fundament
master linda im dienst von 20 seltener
Kosmos ich stehe auf krajina komprimieren julia
Massage putin, aber wenn wenig gefunden
dann wählt niemand anderes gesponsert, den ich will
wenn möglich
darüber, was Sie brauchen
wenigstens irgendwo da demütigen
leider keine sicheren Socken an
[Musik]
Hintern denken Sie an wilden Schnitt
unheimlich
Ich weiß nicht
Ich möchte wirklich mein geliebtes Kiew zurückgeben
kitzeln napura dann Schleier durch was
Schütteln des Umschlags nur Pfeifen von Feigen und Schleier
Zaun
wir setzen alles in Gefangenschaft wer
[Musik]
so in diesem unfall ende und
aliman persönlich ukraine von lustig
Unfälle behandeln wir Handschuh
Eugen
Modelle auf dem Weg und
erfolgreich Ärger
er erzählte ihm von meinem Fund und meinem Balkon
hinter
Monat
[Musik]
zumindest durch die Art des Sprachrausches
ai spik russisch getan ist wie
Sein
wie er sein
Damit
sondern
wenn der Mensch das geringe Gewicht perfilov
jahr koyama und im tanz nebenan und sein
Idps von Menschen werden unter Facebook gehen
Futsal startet man einzeln
Metal Plus und Lügen sind einige Mai
ram ok Physik auf dem Backblech selbst
grüne stadt zum telefonieren auf anblick
Panikwaffen wie entweder Morden Farm on
die leute diese arbeit landen und jetzt
man sieht sich in einem down auf die menschen an
Lüge
diese Wissenschaft und neuer Film über Guy Bridge
getötet ruf mich an ich kaufe das telefon oder kaufe
unzureichende chen un kommentare und liebe
einen ganzen Monat zu deinen Tönen hat er an
die Telefonnummer von diesem helfen wir Ihnen weiter
Destillation Bassist Band Mieder zu mir dort
ballade im on alliance i ist immer noch eine sphäre und
gesammelte filmsprache licht kudrin shpiga zone
und der Moment konvergierte
ist hoch pangloss ist alina nachname
hier erinnert sich putin an ihn von kanada
Regenschirm
auto ukraine tag i tiflis bibel spritze
situation k schokolade afrika jedi hd
zu Hause knacken
eine Meile durch die Ritzen des Falls
Das ist die Art und Weise, wie Utoya Holly Man of the Nation kodiert
bereits für und moshe Sofa Tschechowitsch Stickstoff
am Fuße der Dünen Nation und Zähne mit 15
Moloso-Stimme
aber Ivan Frenkel in Folge Autoraucher
Ukraine auf was haben wir unsere Pfänder
Wir lieben Russland
Jahre Maulmond zurückgerollt und Fahrgestellnummer y
Bad Smog Ohren Ball Rüssel Basis
die nation hat lena knyazeva top gimme dieses alter
haben das Recht, meinen Schülern den Weg frei zu machen
in pflege von handy
gegenseitige Schahada 10
cm
Ruhe, keine Betrüger zu Hause
für immer Zonen Maschinen maximal haben sie sie
Not groß und am Boden frech weiter
Nacken
warum verbrennen
für froh und unsere Kirchen frech
baby us racing auf colymbia hatte das nicht
sprechen china gambia